so no wonder my sense of pattern
recognition is off most jobs Whedon
produced shows don't really get going
till their second season marvel's agents
of shield we are halfway through the
second season of the show and while it's
on its hiatus before comes back i want
to get my thoughts out about the second
season cuz it's a big enough improvement
that it's definitely worth pointing out
if you haven't seen my review and recap
of the entirety of the first season of
this show short version is that it was
very generic up until it integrated with
the main Marvel Cinematic Universe and
shield basically was taken apart by
Hydra then it got more interesting but I
was really doubtful that i was in even
gonna bother coming back for a second
season well I did and I'm really glad
I'll talking about this thing I am gonna
jump around I'm not gonna do this
episode by episode and I'm not gonna
have any real regard for whether or not
anything I say is a spoiler so if you're
not currently caught up with the second
season of agents of shield you might
want to tune out on this unless you
don't care in which case stick around
right off the bat this thing just was so
much better in the previous season one
of the main things that it really has
going for it is the fact that shield is
reeling back on its heels a bit Coulson
especially is working much better my
preferred version of calls it honestly
is the version that we got in the movies
the guy who's in the field who's seen
enough that he's not automatically
impressed by Thor or iron man yet still
has that little fanboy thing going on
when he meets Captain America I kind of
like that as a field agent once shield
started it was very clear that while
he's not just a field agent he's gone
through too much he's been too important
he's come back for the dead from crying
out loud they upgraded him for that and
last season he was kind of this middle
management guy and it never really
worked it never felt right now he's the
head of shield and it works much better
another thing the season got right
immediately was a gave us a clear
identifiable villain in the form of
Whitehall I mean we did not know much
about this guy we didn't know what his
deal was we knew he was a Nazi way back
when but we see him in modern day and he
has an age so there's something weird
going on there but it gives us a face we
go there's our
villain and that was one of the things
that the first season really severely
lacked because there was always talk of
the clairvoyant but it was kept in the
shadow so long that had by the Thunder
real happen I didn't really care anymore
and it was too nebulous to be
threatening they tried to make Reina
threatening but she just she's just not
she works for a certain amount of
intrigue but she's not intimidating so
there was a real kind of villain vacuum
the first season now of course why fall
at this point is actually on the picture
and we now have Skye's father
effectively taking over the villain role
although talking villains that means i
need to bring up ward now I was really
annoyed that they didn't kill word at
the end of last season because I was
positive this season they were gonna
eventually let him out of jail or
wherever he was and have some form of a
Redemption are for him which I feel I
felt very strongly that he did not
deserve and I still feel that and
thankfully they didn't do it no
redemption not only did they not try and
redeem him they doubled down on the
badness of me flat out evil I think if
they weren't gonna get rid of him at the
end of last season this was absolutely
the way to go and rather than try and
get audiences to forgive the betrayal
that he did of the team last season they
just make it that much worse than you
feel like oh my god he knows this team
and he got under the skin so bad and
he's this bat and just as a character
he's so much more interesting now is he
was so generic before I also like what
they've done with Fitzsimmons although I
think they kind of wussed out on it a
little bit i mean right off the bat with
Fitz the fact that he has suffered
pretty severe brain damage from what
happened to him at the end of the last
season that in and of itself immediately
just makes him a more dynamic character
and then the fact that he was basically
hallucinating a version of Simmons who
was understanding and compassionate to
him that was really interesting I
honestly kind of wish that they had the
real Simmons either get killed or not
come back as soon as she did because I
really liked that dynamic where he was
communicating with this other sign of
himself and then as
sure to realize that even knows that's
not the real Simmons but he's still just
embracing it cuz it's all these God it
just made fits a way more interesting
character than he was before Simmons
coming back and Simmons has been awash
now that she's not part of this
archetypal power nerd duo she's working
better she's slightly less generic now
but she hasn't kind of been elevated the
way that fits has skies also become
fairly interesting I mean if you don't
know the way what happened particularly
in that last episode before the break
started and how that ties into the
Inhumans I'm not gonna wreck it up for
you like i said i'll split what's
already happened i won't spoil future
stuff but knowing that they're already
planning in any humans movie i would not
have thought they would have tossed so
much very fundamental law of the
Inhumans into the TV show that they're
gonna have no guarantee enough people
watch and then go see the movie I mean
when they make the Inhumans film they
can't depend on people having seen stuff
from the show so I never would have
thought they would have put so much
essential stuff in into the show so
power to them for doing it agent Mays
just kind of coasting but haces she was
awesome last season so she continues to
be awesome I also got to give this show
props for killing off at least one major
character because they took out trip
then there's the new blood and we've
gotten some good stuff there too cuz now
we've got Bobby Moore's which is a nice
additional bit of sort of badassness
that has a different feel to it from
agent May so that the works and it
doesn't feel redundant we've also got
the mercenary kind of character her
ex-husband who is also just a lot of fun
think it's kind of nice in these
situations where things are very dire
and everyone's taking things seriously
to have at least one character is kind
of going you're kidding me right and
saying it with sincerity and just
overall really the show has become
something that i will now actually
recommend people see I would actually
almost say to skip season one you pick
up enough of what's been going on just
from the way things move forward to
season to start with season two and just
go or if you really have to pick up from
the point in season one where it links
up with Captain America the Winter
Soldier this season it feels like it's
building it feels like it's going
somewhere feels like parts of a coherent
and cohesive whole the first season
until it
I am with the main universe it felt like
it was training water and going nowhere
but it's not doing that anymore it's got
its feet on the ground and it's headed
firmly in a direction and that just
makes the show so much more interesting
you does not feel like it's treading
water anymore or trying to maintain some
status quo between movies it now
actually feels like it's part of that
universe and it's a relevant part of
that universe so I am excited for it to
come back I've been watching aging
Carter in the meantime once on the last
of those episode airs I may give my
thoughts on that well I guess that's
about it for me so have you been
following agents of shield do you think
that this season is better than the
first one did you actually like the
first one better if so I definitely want
to hear why drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned